- Good morning believe nation
today's message is
learn how to deal with criticism.
Over to you James Franco.
(rooster sound)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- You know when you're a creative person
and you're putting your
work out in the world,
sometimes that criticism is biting,
sometimes it's harmful.
And so you just kind of have to be aware
of that.
And one of the reasons,
and figure out a way to kind of
deal with that.
And figure out who
you're going to listen to
and who you're not going to listen to
for your feedback.
Because I do believe
feedback is incredibly important.
And it's one of the reasons
that I,
when I teach,
I also design my classes this way.
So that they can't put their work out
into the world.
That's the final step.
Seeing how your work is being read.
By audiences,
by critics if you care to listen to them.
And so,
and that is the final ingredient
that will make you better.
Because if you're making movies,
you're making television,
you're making videos.
Whatever you're making.
My guess is your making it
to communicate,
to,
for an audience to read it.
You're not just making it,
for yourself to kind of watch.
Unless you know,
you're making like,
I don't know.
Porn with you and your partner
or something like that.
(audience laughter)
To get off on.
Like you're making it for an audience.
Like,
and so,
so understanding how it's communicating
to that audience,
is incredibly important.
So, I do value feedback.
But you just have to under ...
Like one of the things you learn
in any MFA program,
you know if it's writing
or filmmaking,
or art,
or whatever is ...
Because they're usually run
in a workshop manner.
You know,
you're getting feedback
from your classmates and your teachers,
on your work constantly.
And one of the things you learn
in that system is,
well ...
His feedback is always lame,
he does not understand
what I am trying to do.
He's like wrapped up in his own thing.
Or he's angry about
the way that I dress or something ...
Like his feedback is worthless.
Okay.
But she has always
you know
given me good feedback.
And actually when I listen to her
it makes myself better.
And ...
And you just apply that
to the larger world like,
okay, this critic
has some little,
you know, drum to beat.
And he just doesn't ...
Whatever.
He's off on his own thing,
and he can,
You know.
Beat the hate drum.
Fine, I don't care.
This critic,
you know.
Gets it.
And if I,
Oh.
It made some great insight.
Okay.
That will help me on the next one.
And, so you just have to kind of learn
who to listen to,
and who not to listen to.
And if somebody is telling you
Just plain out,
don't do that,
you're not allowed to write books,
you're not allowed to direct.
Like.
I would just give the advice of
don't listen to them.
- I think this is a really important topic
because as entrepreneurs,
we are going to get faced
with a ton of criticism
as we are trying to build something new,
put it out into the market.
Try to get some feedback.
Try to build something.
We're doing something that's
never been done before.
Ideally as entrepreneurs
we like creating new stuff.
And when you're doing that
you're going to make a lot of mistakes.
And people don't always like new.
And they are going to bash you for it.
There's two things I want to talk about.
The first is,
you need to understand
that to have success
as an entrepreneur,
you need to combine
what you love doing,
with what adds value to other people.
This is the mix.
You need both elements.
Something that you love doing
and you can pour your heart,
your energy,
your spirit.
Everything you got.
Your waking moments,
hours,
days,
into making this thing
the best it can be
because you love it so much.
Combined with
what the market wants.
What do your audience want?
What do customers want to pay for.
You need both to have
success in business.
Because if you love doing something.
You love it,
it's your absolute passion,
but it adds zero value to other people.
Then it's great.
It's a hobby.
It's something that you do for yourself,
that fills your soul.
Makes you a better human being.
It's awesome.
But it's not a business.
Where,
if you're only chasing
the market.
You're chasing the hottest opportunity.
Then yeah,
you can make a little bit of money
in the short term.
But if you don't love it,
you're never going to
to be the best at it.
You're never going to win that game.
You're never going to
have a lot of success
in business.
So you need both.
The love,
and the audience acceptance.
So, the love has to come from inside.
The audience acceptance
comes from feedback.
Comes from criticism.
Comes from talking to customers
and understanding
what to they want?
How can you help them.
When I look at the videos I make
on this channel,
most of the content
and the ideas
comes from you guys.
What do you want in the next
top 10 list.
For do you want for the next
believe life series.
Right.
All of these things
come from you guys
giving me suggestions,
and saying
hey, this video can be better.
I like that intro.
I don't like that intro.
Give me feedback on what
I can improve.
Now I take all your feedback
and criticism,
and suggestions.
And then I see,
do I want to do that or not.
Do I love it.
Right.
Make a top ten on this person.
Make a series on this idea.
You know.
If I'm not connected to it,
I'm not going to pick it.
This is where we are playing our game.
We're dancing right,
you have two people in a dance.
And that's where you have to
always be in harmony.
Between what you really want to do
and what the market wants as well.
So the criticism and the feedback
is super important
to get that harmony happening.
The other thing
that I want to talk about quickly,
is one of my favorite quotes,
and it's from Quincy Jones.
And we did an Entspresso on.
And a top ten on it I think.
Where he said,
'Not one ounce of my self respect,
comes from your opinion of me.'
And I think this is so important.
Especially for the early
stages of an entrepreneur.
Because as you're building your thing up
you may have this big idea.
That you maybe you don't
even really believe in yet either.
Right.
You want to be here,
but you're still playing down here.
And you're afraid.
And you haven't even convinced yourself
that you're ready to go there.
Let alone telling other people about it.
And when you tell other
people about your idea,
they may laugh at you,
they may make fun of you,
they may tell you all the reasons why
it's not going to work.
And so you are afraid
to go and tell other people about
what you are trying to do.
And you need to get help right,
you need people to poke holes
into your idea,
and help you find the path.
Because you can't do everything yourself.
And so, understand that,
you're going to get criticized.
Some people will be really nice about it,
and really constructive about it,
and give you a positive message with it.
And some people won't.
Some people just tell you
that it's crap.
And they will insult you over it.
But it doesn't mean that they
don't necessarily have a point.
And you need to differentiate between
a personal attack on you
versus an attack on the idea,
and how it can be better.
And if somebody
personally attacks you.
Who cares.
Like, stop caring so much
about what other people think about you.
Not one ounce of my self respect
comes from your opinion of me.
You don't like my top ten video.
Okay.
You know, I wrote a great book.
I love the book.
So far all the reviews of the book
have been pretty good.
But if you don't like my book.
Okay.
Like, it's not for every single
human being on this planet.
And your negative thoughts
around my book
is not going to make me feel
worse about myself.
Or about the amazing piece of work
that I created.
And if you don't like
that I wear a hat sometimes.
Or you don't like my hoodie,
or my T-shirt.
Or think I should be in a suit.
Or anything.
It doesn't impact me.
I got to do me.
I don't care.
And so learning
to be able to handle that.
To be able to take criticism,
and not let it impact you
on a personal self worth level.
And differentiate between,
this can actually help me,
make something better.
And this is useless.
Because you need to get to the point
where you're combining
what you love doing.
Your passion.
Where you can be the best in the world
at potentially.
With what people want
and you can add value to them.
Mix these together.
That's a successful business.
So the question of the day today is,
I am curious,
how do you handle criticism?
What do you do?
I'm curious what your thought process is.
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick shoutout
to Jonathan Lao.
Jonathan thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book
'Your One Word'.
It really, really, really, really,
means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is.
And I will see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot,
of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Hey guys, so I decided to add
a couple extra bonus clips
just for you
around this topic
of being able to handle criticism
that I hope you will enjoy
as a bonus.
- There's four things
when somebody gives you feedback
or criticism.
However it is intended,
whether it is ill
or positive.
And so one is,
not to take it in,
but to catch it.
I think of it like a catchers mitt.
If you tell me something,
and you come across this way.
I'll grab it.
And I'm going to look at it,
and I'll think, okay.
Is it true?
If it's true,
cool I will put it in and learn from it.
If I think it's not true,
cool, I will throw it away.
No harm, no foul,
I'm not going to dwell on it.
Right.
And I think everybody needs this
in this world.
Because we're all on,
most of us are on social media,
and we're al getting like ...
(host laughs)
You know, all our thoughts are getting
picked apart.
You know, all the time.
So we really need this more than ever.
Then the third one is,
you get it, and it's a maybe.
Well I'm not sure,
you said this about me.
I'm not sure.
You know, what do you guys think?
You know, what do you think?
I'll ask my friends,
and I'll ask other people
and get some feedback,
and if it's true,
cool, maybe I'll learn from it.
If everyone is like
this is total nonsense,
ignore that dude.
I throw it out.
But then there is a fourth one,
and this where the real growth is.
Do you know what the fourth one is?
- I don't.
- [Neil] The fourth one is,
you get it.
You throw it out.
I'm talking to you,
and maybe later I'm talking to,
you know, you.
I get it.
And I'm like,
nah, it's not true. ,I throw it out.
And then later I'm
talking to someone else,
I get it.
It's the third time it's come back to me.
I throw it out, I'm like wait.
Maybe I got to take thing thing
a little more seriously.
- [Host] Right.
- And it becomes a maybe.
And then it becomes a yes.
And that's when the big growth thing is,
because you kept ignoring this thing
that was in your face.
So the best feedback,
like where you really grow,
is you keep getting the same feedback.
You keep dismissing it.
At some point you say wait.
Maybe they have something.
So, one way I do this is.
I get together a group of people.
And we sit together once a week.
And talk a lot of stuff
going on in our lives.
I find group therapy really powerful.
Because if it's just one on one,
I can just say I disagree with you.
But when four or five people are saying,
hey dude, no your really
coming off like that.
Or your really having this
problem in your relationship.
Then maybe you need to look at it.
And five people are saying it.
Like it's pretty hard to dismiss it.
- In hip hop it's like, yo he's gay as
(censored)
dog, like
that dude.
Like you know what I mean.
Like I just ... Why don't you like him?
You know what,
he can rap.
He got a good story.
His flows are cool.
For sure.
I just don't like him though.
Like and it's so ignorant,
it's crazy.
So, like yeah,
years ago,
you know what I'm saying.
When I first got on blogs,
and I'd be excited.
I'd read comments.
But now it's just like,
there's no point to read comments.
- Yeah, don't read the comments.
- Yeah, it's honestly.
Yeah.
It's either too positive.
Which can lead you to like be big headed.
Or it's too negative,
which can make you try to
create music to get them to stop
hating on you.
It's like somebody being like,
yeah, he should rap like this,
he should rap like that.
I don't like the way he raps.
And then the person
changes up how they rap.
To try to, you know,
make that person like them.
And then they're like,
man he ain't even being himself.
Like after you change ...
(host laughs)
So it's like you can't win man.
- Right.
- You can't win no matter what you do.
- Right, for sure.
- [Logic] So for me, I
don't listen to the hate.
I don't listen to love too much.
I just, you know.
Take it all in stride.
Like I love what I do.
And as long as I can wake
up everyday and feel that,
I feel like I'm doing right.
- [Interviewer] Do you read
criticism, of yourself?
- No.
I use to.
I use to, and then I realized,
it wasn't helpful.
- [Interviewer] Positive or negative?
- Mmhmm
- [Interviewer] It's just a distraction?
- Yeah I can't,
I don't look at anything anymore
that's written, whether
it's like interviews,
or I mean ...
(Interviewer laughs)
It's just,
it's also just too much focus on yourself.
- [Interviewer] Mmhmm
- It's like,
I am far from the center of the world
and I don't need to like,
I need to read about other things
(Natalie laughs)
There is a lot of really
good things to read
about and,
I know about myself and,
if someone makes a mistake about me
I'm just going to get upset so ...
- [Interviewer] Mmhmm
- Or if they say something
negative I'm going to get upset
And if they say something nice.
That's friendly but I also don't need
to care.
Like I don't need to
base my sense of self on
what strangers opinions of me are,
like,
it's important to me that my friends,
my family,
you know, think that
I'm behaving correctly.
And, they will let me know
If I'm out of line and,
and everyone else's opinions like,
You know.
It's not my business.